[Music]
you're very tall in and when you got
into acting when you left modeling you
got into acting
was it difficult when you're working
with actors male actors that are shorter
than you you know because a lot of them
people don't realize but we've had them
come on big movie stars and some of them
are smaller than than you'd think I mean
the I I did a film with Sylvester
Stallone Arnold Schwarzenegger and the
first day on set and I was very nervous
because obviously you know it's very
surreal and you know they're huge but I
was sitting down and and sly walks in
and I stand up to shake his hand and
he's like who ordered the giraffe yeah
and they're gonna dig a trench for you
to stand in yeah
what's all about Outlander this is a
period drama the Wardrobe is very
intricate and layered and they want to
be authentic to the times because it
takes place several hundred years ago so
I think we have a still of picture up
here of your wardrobe and they do a
gorgeous job on the show but what's
always confusing is there's there's sex
scenes love themes on the show and you
think about how quickly can someone get
out of those clothes if they feel the
need to the foreplay of unlacing a
thousand corset yeah it's eight hours of
which is just unknotting stuff they're
what they're dagger and you know no it's
really funny a costume designer Terry
dress back who does such an incredible
job I think she always sits on the
production meetings and she's you know
in in the line they'll be like and her
clothes fell off and they make love and
she's like really really you know do you
have 25 minutes to show this you know
how is this gonna happen it's just this
before you know what they need it velcro
in layers for that but Terry likes to do
things historically accurately but ya
know it's it's funny it's like they have
this idea that it's just so romantic and
everything's gonna happen in an instant
but there's like 15 layers of
there so it need to be yeah exactly I
would I mean I in the modern era
I have trouble it's just you know bra
strap couldn't do it you know one what
the hook that still can't do it
no yeah you can't do it with one hand oh
god no no what do you think I'm a
magician god no
you